[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تجمع المئات هنا في شارع الرشيد بالقرب من
مبنى البنك المركزيين من محافظات بابل
والنجف وحتى بغداد والمحافظات الجنوبيه
مطالبينا بخفض سعر صرف الدولار والذي وصل
الى بدايات القياسيه
[موسيقى]
العراق من وسطه من جنوبه
يطالبون مطالب شرعيه منها خفض سعر الدولار
الذي اصبح كاهل على الشعب العراقي بعده
مكان 120 118 صعد الى 150 بمقابل الدولار
العمله الاجنبيه وبعدين صعد الى 160 167
ربما 177
[موسيقى]
مطالب المتظاهرين تنوعت بين ايقاف تهريب
العمله ومحاسبه المضاربين داخل الاسواق
الماليه
يضاف لها عقد جلسه طارئه لمجلس النواب
لمناقشه ارتفاع سعر صرف الدولار امام
الدينار انهيار الدينار العراقي بما معنى
انهيار الدوله والسبب الاساسي لكل هذا هو
تهريب العمله ثانيا يجب ان تكون الحكومه
جاده وذات باعث وطني حقيقي
لايجاد حل لهذه المساله احنا شو بدنا نعمل
عقوبات دول احنا شعب نطالب يعني اول شيء
احنا كل الدول مو بس العراق كل الدول
تحارب من اجل العمته من اجل الصعيد عمتها
احنا عكس الدول نحارب من اجل نزل العملات
مقابل العمله الاجنبيه
تظاهره انتهت بشكل سلبي بالاتفاق بين
القوات الامنيه والمتظاهرين لكن
المتظاهرين هددوا في حال لم يتم الاستجابه
لهذه المطالب بتظاهرات اكبر وربما حتى
اوسع في بغداد والمحافظات
[موسيقى]
بشارع الرشيد في بغداد سامر الكبيسي
العربيه
[موسيقى]